i'm brian lindsey i'm ashley lindsay we
love each other and we've always loved
each other i was signing for student
loans for my wife because i thought
that's what husbands do yeah i'll sign
for her to get another student loan and
the whole time it's ridiculous i was i
just didn't have a clue my wife when she
was pregnant i remember as a husband
near weeping because i couldn't go out
and buy her jeans that would fit i had a
rubber band
that would hold my pants so that they
would could grow with me
so
yeah it was bad
i thought we made all the right
decisions
but i didn't know that we had this huge
issue i thought everything was fine
because we didn't have credit card debt
and we didn't have all these other
things and we didn't owe for our cars
and we didn't owe for all this stuff so
i thought we're awesome we're great and
the whole time we're underwater and i
didn't realize it you know i didn't
really understand i thought dave
ramsey's message was don't do credit
cards and don't do you know car loans
buy your cars with cash i thought that
was his message but it was so much more
and when i started look at it i realized
you know
we messed up when he said we need to
really buckle down on this dave ramsey i
was like let's do it
and he downloaded the internet program
with a budget
that really really helped us see where
our where our cash was going our first
big loan
was
like for like four grand
and we paid it off we were um ecstatic
we brian made me look at the computer
when he pays it i'm getting ready to
enter we are getting ready to pay off
our first loan
and so we sat there and as he pushed
enter and it was like zero balance
i mean there was just silence in the
room and then like we went to kroger and
got a big steak and eight and we're like
yes this is the first one it's gone
it was just amazing
it was a saturday night four days before
christmas when the house burned it's
devastating we felt like we lost
everything when our house burned down
you can feel sorry for yourself
we can lay in bed all day you can put
the brakes on the some of the ministry
we're doing we can we can just put the
brakes on and figure this out
and we the day when that night when we
were late in the hotel brian said we're
not going to push the brakes on this
and sunday was the next morning so we
caught all the people from the church
and we said we're having service
tomorrow
and
we are going to come through this and
we're going to come through it
with um with joy
it's weird i hadn't been back over here
in a while i went and got a shovel and
was looking through some just different
areas of the house and
and i found a little piece of my son
memphis baby book and the footprints
were still there
i mean we just sat cried
and i was like i'm so glad you found
these
it's got ashes all around it and it's
got his hand print and his little
footprints there the moment disaster
came
we didn't have to wait long for hope our
entrance policy was going to be a help
and
we're on the debt-free journey so i told
her i said i just don't
think that we can
replace everything because if we do
we're going to stay in debt do you want
that bedroom furniture
or do you want to pay off a loan and it
things just began to get beautiful
people would just come and bless us
it was amazing
my wife had nicer clothes than she'd
ever had in her whole life and she
didn't buy any of them somebody just
brought them to us and we didn't have to
go in debt for them and we would have
refused to go in debt
for
we got things that were beautiful
because that's what the lord wanted for
us at that moment but we had lived in
disaster even before the fire it is like
you can breathe and so after that it was
not hard to take that money and pay off
the rest of the money
we're dead friends
we are givers and that's where our heart
has always been but it's been difficult
so now we have the opportunity to be
able to do that and we love it
because we're we're not in debt
we're not tied to um some company that
we have to give them all of our money i
can give money to some other family that
has a fire we always gave whenever the
lord led
but now we can give when the lord leads
or when we just feel like it
because i'm debt-free god didn't tell me
but i may just buy somebody's lunch
tomorrow not because i have to
but because i can